James good morning thanks for joining us
how are you you know I remember when
they used to say that's where for losers
but but now it's because we can get
every stat we want we get these all time
stats what happened and when and you
said barroom conversations and just
disagree now somebody pulls out their
phone or their tablet and they have a
factor of death yeah but the thing with
this these stats it just about the games
themselves so it's not about individuals
I think with individuals you can
sometimes look at Carson Wentz and say
boy you had a great game and somebody
might look at the film and say well
maybe he didn't or dak Prescott or you
know the rg3 so I understand her from an
individual standpoint but the fact that
you've had these games so close and he
had a close one last night with the
Patriots and the Cardinals what were
your expectations of the Patriots going
into that game well the game of the
whole the expectation level for the
Cardinals was through the roof you know
high scoring team a lot of veterans you
know Carson Palmer Larry Fitzgerald and
then you looked at the Patriots and you
go look at all the guys that didn't make
the trip not like they were sending the
junior varsity team because their
defense is great they have Bill
Belichick Josh McDaniels offensive
coordinator so you knew that they would
come up with something to kind of keep
the game relatively close which you
didn't realize Garoppolo would take the
team down and score on the first drive
and he would have those moments during
the game where you're going boy this
this kid is really good really good well
I think the third down completion
percentage it that he was pretty
impressive when he had to be and these
were worn long third downs that he had
to complete and he was buying time in
the in the pocket and that last drive we
know that that's big boy stuff there I
thought Garoppolo out of all of the new
quarterbacks stood out because of what
he did and where he did it against a
team that people think could go to the
Super Bowl well and they were able to
pick on the correct people whether
the rookie corner whether it's the
strong safety was trying to cover Julian
Edelman in the slot he executed exactly
what the game plan masters wanted him to
do it wasn't like he went off-script
this is where we have to get them this
is what we want to attack Patrick
Peterson be careful throwing the ball
over there he's pretty good everybody
else pregame yeah but you have a pass
rush you get Chandler Jones Robert can
DJ I mean you're ready to go I I was
really surprised and actually
disappointed with what I saw with
Arizona I I thought it would be a far
more and I know Bella check takes away
what you love to do best that's throw a
deep but you still have Johnson who's a
very good running back I thought the
defense was going to be better than what
it was you know i'm not sure if if
midseason form which is what we wanted
to arizona cardinals to resume with what
was anywhere close to that nature yeah
carson palmer was a little bit off
you're right the coverage was a little
bit off here they had pressure in the in
the second half they were making plays
on the patriots side of the line of
scrimmage but they couldn't convert
those into stops they couldn't convert
them really into in eternal was 18 when
they did score it was off a short fields
a couple times roll in the game Larry
Fitzgerald last night certainly that
final drive looked like a hall-of-famer
historically how are we going to
remember Larry Fitzgerald well the first
impression that we have of them is in
the Super Bowl and when he was a young
player and he's Britain down the middle
of field and when you when you watch and
play he took a couple of hits on
crossing routes that that made me want
to go ice my knees I mean he's a big
receiver so he was hit right where he
bends right at the knee and I'm thinking
he may not get up after this he pops up
gives the ball to the official jogs back
to the huddle there is there was a
beauty about watching him play yeah yeah
have a chance to go on some vacations
with my wife to Europe and you go see
these wonderful sites these historic
sites if you are a football purist you
want to enjoy watching Larry Fitzgerald
play I know somebody leaked it this
might be as last year
that seems strange watching him play
last night you see the David or Mona
Lisa he would be the David where you
would just stand there and you would
just gaze at him talking to James loft
in Westwood One NFL analyst he called
the Patriots in the Cardinals last night
what stood out the rest of the NFL
yesterday I think the thing that stood
out for me and you touched on it earlier
is that as I was flipping channels and
watching games on the computer here I
thought okay this game is in hand and
then you come back to it a couple of
later and the other teams a hit so that
that drama that was in all seems like
every NFL stadium over the weekend was
consistent so here we waited through the
draft through the offseason through the
OTAs through training camp through a
very boring preseason and we got more
than what we expected at the box office
in week one so far this season if I said
you could pick a quarterback 25 and
under to start a team and I gave you a
bortles Winston whens mario de Garoppolo
Derek Carr dak Prescott who would you
take well I had a the chance to be
around Jameis Winston when he was
getting ready for the draft and there is
there was an electric personality around
him and the fact that he reformed his
body because he used to be a little
chubby yeah he reformed his body going
into a second year so there's a
seriousness about his play and so I like
him i also have tutored his two
receivers inch in jackson and mike evans
so there's a connection there and i
always like jumping on the bandwagon so
i'll jump on Jameis Winston's bandwagon
I like Mike Evans I mean that that
that's that's one of those where you
just say all right I'm gonna throw it up
and he'll come down go get it yeah yeah
and Vincent Jax I mean these guys 65
you're seeing it now some teams go
everybody's got to be six foot and under
it seems like with the Patriots and then
you get these other teams that everybody
the Carolina wide receivers James when I
I was in Denver and year-round Funchess
Kelvin Benjamin
Olson those are big boys oh my god but
you know that's the great thing about
the NFL one size doesn't fit all you
take your top five receivers and if you
put them all together you go none of
them look the same you take Antonio
Brown Julio Jones Dez Bryant maybe AJ
Green throwing somebody else's you know
I'm leaving off the list and you go no
too had the same body type but they
accomplish the same things Sunday night
you've got vikings packers did you see
enough do you think the Vikings saw
enough with shaun hill that shaun hill
will get the start against Green Bay boy
that that's a tough one when you when
you pay a big price for a new toy you
you want to use it so you first-round
pick and at least a fourth-round pick in
the following year for Sam Bradford
Viking plant fans are gonna be clamoring
for you know the new guy and that may be
the last time they clamor for James good
to talk to you safe travels and thanks
for joining us thank you Dad thanks for
having me on all right James Lofton
westwood one NFL analyst the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience
[Music]